empezaremos ahora con este número te
tenemos siete millones 346 mil
quinientos 21.30 y dos milésimos
vamos a pensar y me voy a fijar
específicamente en dos números este 3
y este 3
lo haré porque vamos a analizar el valor
posicional y compararemos en el sentido
de qué tan grande es este 3 comparado
con este mismo 3 de acuerdo al valor
posicional que cada uno está ocupando y
para analizar el valor posicional
empezaremos desde las unidades este uno
se encuentra en las unidades
si nos recorremos hacia el lado derecho
estaremos pensando en que cada cambio de
valor posicional nos representa una
décima parte del valor del lado
izquierdo o una división entre 10 así es
que los decimos
un décimo o una décima parte de esta
unidad
si nos recorremos a las dos centésimas
tendremos centésimos este es el valor de
los centésimos y el valor posicional de
los miles y mos
ahora hacia la izquierda es distinto
hacia la izquierda lo que realmente
estamos haciendo es multiplicar por 10
en cada cambio de valor posicional es
decir que en las decenas tendremos
10 unidades estas son las decenas sea el
número que esté aquí será multiplicado
por 10 porque ese es el valor que está
representando hacia las centenas
nos recorremos a la izquierda
multiplicando por 10 de la misma manera
las unidades de millar
estas son las unidades de millar las
decenas de millar
las centenas de millar
centenas de millar y las unidades de
millón
unidades de millón ahora si pensamos en
este 3 y este 3
lo que tenemos es este 3
esta x 100.000
este 3 en la posición de las centenas de
millares representa un 3 x 100 mil
lo que será igual
300.000
vamos con el otro tres que tenemos aquí
es exactamente el mismo número es un 3
sin embargo el valor posicional lo
tenemos en las centésimas y esto lo que
nos significa es que tenemos un 3
multiplicado por una centésima o lo que
es igual
centésimos como lograríamos saber qué
tan grande es este 3 respecto a este 3
no podemos pensar de la siguiente manera
si nosotros multiplicamos cada posición
de valor hacia la izquierda estaremos
haciendo un cambio multiplicando por 10
por 10 x 10 por 10 y así tendríamos que
este 3 para llegar al valor posicional
de este 3 haría un cambio o haría una
multiplicación por diez
por 10 x 10 x 10 x 10 x 10 x 10 es decir
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 desplazamientos o 7 veces
x 10 así es que si pensamos en llegar
estos 3 centésimos a 300.000 pensaríamos
en multiplicar
centésimos
por 17 veces por 10 x 10 x 10 x 10 por
y por 10 recuerda que cada uno de estos
son el cambio o el desplazamiento que
hemos tenido al multiplicar por 10 desde
esta posición hasta esta así es que
tenemos 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 si nosotros
multiplicamos por 10 varias veces lo que
tendremos es una multiplicación por 1
con 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 ceros 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 si
volviéramos a multiplicar por 10
añadiríamos ceros sin embargo en este
momento solo lo haremos por 7
y multiplicaremos entonces 3
centésimos
por 10 millones
si nosotros hacemos esta multiplicación
tendríamos realmente 3 por 10 millones
estos 10 millones realmente son unidades
están sobre 1 así es que si hacemos la
división
tendríamos que eliminamos dos ceros y se
elimina este 100 así es que nos
quedaremos con 3
y uno dos tres cuatro cinco ceros uno
dos tres cuatro cinco ceros tenemos
entonces 300.000 que si efectivamente
son los mismos
300.000
que tenemos de este lado nosotros lo que
hicimos fue multiplicar estos 3
centésimos por 10 millones para llegar
al valor posicional de los 300.000 si lo
escribimos de otra manera
este 3
10 millones
el valor de este 3 únicamente por la
diferencia del valor posicional en el
que se encuentran